spain the wars against islam continued the year 1031 on into the 12th and 13th centuries kingdom
of aragon included sardinia southern italy and sicily france and england were soon to discover
that spain had become more powerful than they in 1469 a series of plots resulted in the marriage
of isabella of castile and ferdinand of aragon of burish possessions nothing was left but the
kingdom of granada which didn't last long anyway what if we sent these guys swimming ah shucks the
The fun was just the beginning, eh, boy?
In 1487, Malaga fell.
In that same year, Bartomeu Deas rounded the Cape of Good Hope.
And just as I was losing hope, she stepped outside.
A rose, she plucked this fucking wizard.
That's all I'll say.
It was a night for love.
By 1492, Granada, Islam's last stronghold, had fallen.
After five centuries of fighting, the Spaniards' hatred for the Moors had reached fever pitch.
In Spain, the new humanism had difficulty taking root.
The Inquisition had begun with the ruthless Torquemada in charge.
And so an edict has just proclaimed the banishment of the Jews,
some of whom have lived in Spain for a thousand years.
Folks, what a pity to have to chase them away.
A man named Columbus has finally persuaded the Catholic kings to sponsor his crazy dream
to reach Japan, India, and Marco Polo's Cathay by sailing westward.
His crew is composed of volunteers.
You don't say!
On board, the spirits are high.
The hardy sailors were spurred on by their lust for adventure.
Santa Maria, the Pinta, and the Nina set out in quest of discovery.
The winds have died down.
Columbus is worried.
The wind's up, the wind's up, we're saved, the wind's up, the wind's up, let's go, all you're back to work.
What, why are we going home, huh?
No, we're heading west.
Oh, hey, Joe.
Onwards, lads, onwards to adventure and gold.
Gold.
Hmm.
Navigating wasn't easy to do in those days.
Columbus did have a few problems.
Charts, let's call them sketches.
As for the compass, astrolabes were rather inefficient.
In short, his three ships were lost.
We ought to be seeing land about now. Let's have a look.
Right there in front of us.
Nothing.
Huh?
Impossible. I won't permit this chart to be wrong.
Do you agree, boys, we ought to see India?
Rave India to the Indians. We're off to Spain, do you hear?
Yes, we're trimming off your neck.
Fine with me.
Off to Spain, whatever could have held me up.
Land!
Are you sure it's land?
Yes, sir. Positive it's land.
Look, it's coming in clear.
Absolutely.
Take a look.
We have succeeded.
We've gone around the earth.
Our deeds will be passed down to posterity.
After 69 valiant days at sea on October 12, 1492, five centuries after the Vikings,
Christopher Columbus discovered America, or rather, one little Caribbean island.
Better than nothing, there would be more conquerors.
John Cabot, Americo Vespucci, Pedro Cabral, and Vasco da Gama.
Just out of the army, our two friends are heading for home.
He's directing the logging.
Hey, watch out.
There he is. Maestro!
My wife, my wife!
At last you're home to stay!
Loves me not. She loves me.
Passionately.
In spite of treaties to the contrary, non-converted
moslems were also banished.
They, along with the Jews, were among Spain's most
industrious citizens. Spain would suffer
the consequences of this loss for centuries.
Hello, my son. My boy.
Look at you.
Now, now, let's not teach
bad habits to my being.
In the same year, 1500, in faraway Flanders, another baby was born who would one day become Emperor Charles V.
Another beauty fell!
Which brings us to the dawn of the 16th century.
As Rome had already done, so would other cultures fade into insignificance.
The Islamic world, China, India, and Europe would move to center stage.
As for Spain, she was clearing her forests to construct ships.
Good idea.
What?
Marvels, are you up to me?
Hey, maestro? Could we please have a look?
Certainly.
Oh, for the main pieces, I follow the shape of certain branches.
When arranged in this way, they'll make sturdy boats.
Just wait, you'll see.
This is what they'll look like.
Oh, yes, well, 1504 is perhaps a little early for such things.
Thirsty?
Here's some bread.
The years go by.
The forests are being depleted.
And the children have grown.
The years 1516, Ferdinand of Aragon, King of Spain, has just died.
Prince Charles of Ghent, too Flemish to suit his father, would nonetheless succeed.
At the age of 16, Charles took the throne of Spain, as well as Italy, Flanders, Artois, and Franche-Comté, not to mention the New World.
All right, children, come and eat.
Before long, another realm would be added to his kingdom, that of his grandfather, Maximilian, the German Empire.
You see, Pablo, if this does persist, before long, we'll be unable to breathe.
with the wood chopped down the animals will run away and hide the country folk will leave their
farms and head for the city and food shortages will be common and i respect senorita kindly
let a courageous warrior tell of his adventures hey wait watch your step you pants myself i cut
the moorish army to pieces so you see i am a hidalgo senorita take a look at my smooth hands
no man you will work for me all i ask of you is a beloved inquisitor
faithful too often you forget your god no wonder our spain is full of conversos jews and muslims
who pretend to believe they are possessed with demons their existence is an offense to the lord
expose each one it's an act of faith that will be richly rewarded he finds innocent but he's
certainly possessed by the devil as for my lady he never goes to church very well this is for you
good man next please his skin is much too brown there's really no doubt this man's one of them
conversos 1519 charles v became emperor immense realm he already controlled tempted him to reunite
all europe and to adopt the habsburg motto the fate of austria is to rule the universe magellan
had begun his trip around the world and court is left to conquer mexico leonardo da vinci had just
passed away at the court of france the first charles chief rival along the loire river new
The castles were being built, another side of chains: Chaumont, Blois, Chenonceau, Azelerideau, Trambo.
But let's hold on a minute and get back to Spain.
Oh, did you see that? Nori, poor beast.
You please, Sr. Orange. It's for a good cause.
Think of that.
I'm sure he's in favor.
Alright, here's the gold in both my friends. Speaking of that word, tell me what is anywhere, Nori.
I'll explain it to you.
Heroes over here.
Ech, these flies!
All sorts of urban in this part of the woods, eh?
Oh, I just splashed one.
How 'bout it? Here.
Thank you.
What a sprightly wine!
So, sir, you approved my apple, huh?
Excuse me, sir, I thought it was...
Don't bother excusing yourself, just keep the apple.
The bill was pretty quiet this morning.
Where's everyone gone?
Take a look in that litter, he remind you of someone?
But, yeah, it's him!
You sense kind, sir? Sir, if you please help.
Fuck, I don't cry. I'm not.
Why should I bother being sadder with that idiot?
The lad's got potential, I believe. Didn't take him much time to figure that one out, eh?
Mmm, no. That didn't do the girl.
I'm a poor blind man, mercy.
Deport?
Oh, over there, that building behind where those kids are playing. Just turn right, you can't miss it.
Oh, thank you, sirs.
Hey, you. Hey.
I'll take my purse. Come on.
All right.
One slap on a boot in the slats for good measure. He learned something today.
look a boat coming into port
a good cargo yes there's a bit of everything just watch you're perfectly aware of my interest
captain what do you mean by that that's what i mean to say these slaves are high grade you want
them hello to me i'm always looking for good merchandise wouldn't mind packing to go on a
long voyage. Me neither. Me, if I'll agree, then let's go. Yes, sir. Yeah. Hey, you, you're in a kind
of a hurry, aren't you? You bet. What a fine life we'd have. A left hook and a right can't wait.
Nothing like a trip to educate our young. There's me. We mustn't forget me. I also want to go and
look for gold, gold, gold. In 1520, Francis I met Henry VIII at the field of the cloth of gold.
Together, they plotted against the king of Spain. But in the end, the English king allied himself
with charles v why didn't they take me 1520 marked the beginning of sillomain the magnificent's reign
in turkey he chose to join forces with francis i martin luther's new theories were raging through
germany he was banished by the young emperor charles who needed the pope on his side against
francis the first the cape should be straight no i mean to port to port yes your wish is my command
no captain housing up your arquebuses at my command man order arms arms now pike exercises
please i'd up for spades if it's all the same to you what about the hearts and clouds
what's the use somebody hold me back i've got an ace of diamonds here somewhere here what
devil's going on we're losing other boats huh but sir i'm only executing your orders i'll show you
Be nice, they clap.
Listen, man, clap these two no-goods in irons and make it quick.
Huh?
That's your orders, my captain. Tell us what you want done with him.
A fine kettle of fish I'm in.
Uh, all right, take the helm and catch up to those ships, right?
Right, chief.
I want to get off this floating prison.
That's what you call me being watch.
Take this.
I'm so sick, I won't last much longer.
Hey, stomach.
Oh, my God.
I'm out of fresh water.
You're gonna get up, you're good for nothing.
Toss me over, bud, why don't you?
You're gonna do what? He says, right this minute.
It's weird, but my strength's all gone.
Unless I'm seeing visions land.
Good idea to bring this horse along.
Much less tiresome than going on foot, and it's impressive.
1821, halfway around the world.
Jelen was one of his men, succeeded in reaching home after a voyage of three years.
Come on, man, it's not much better. Just go where the hell is.
The 237 he started with.
Now there's no doubt, world is round.
She's gone for her morning bath in the river.
You see, I told you so.
I still can't figure out why it's always the men that work.
Yeah, that's right.
Hey, you like it?
What do you think of these old figurines?
Uh, yeah, they're not bad either.
Come and get it.
Met clouds with your smoke.
Leaving our big friend to his pottery,
let's visit someone who specializes in feather mosaics,
the most delicate and prestigious art of all.
Children, keep the noise down.
Let these men go about their work in peace.
Sandwich.
What the?
Your rascal that started it, I saw him.
That's a lie, your boy hit my boy first.
Yes, but not before your boy had already hit my boy.
Yo, fudda-dudda.
What's that you said that, right?
Now, gentlemen, no fighting.
What am I waiting for?
Nature has always been human nature.
When you grow up, you'll become warriors for the glory of the god Yaw.
Your hair will be cut short except for one lock on the nape of the neck.
Then in the countryside.
After that, when you've taken your first prisoner, even if it's taken two of you,
your remaining lock of hair will be cut and you'll be Eyak or half-gods.
Then you can grow your hair as long as you want over your right ear.
The more enemies an Eyak kills or imprisons, the more worthy he becomes.
And if you kill, or even better, if you capture four enemies,
you will win leather bracelets and leather headdresses.
No, he's mine, he's mine, he's mine, he's mine, no, he's my prisoner, he's mine, he's mine, he's mine, he's mine, he's mine.
And you guess what the biggest reward will be for the winner?
The worthy fighter will get to dance with a young and beautiful courtesan
made up in yellow to bring out the glow of her skin.
You'll dance and dance and dance.
What's happened? Why the alarm?
Come on, hurry up, you guys. Come on.
Strangers, they're coming up over the hill.
Let's give a dose of real civilization to these savages.
A small fee in gold will introduce happiness and progress.
All right, my fine-feathered friends, show us what you're made of.
Forward!
In August of the year 1521, Cortes completed his conquest of Mexico.
In that year, there were 12 million Indians in the land.
A few years later, Cortes had butchered half of them.
And in Peru, Pizarro left an even bloodier trail.
The Conquistadores brought Spain vast territories and wealth.
1521, war broke out again with France.
1524, in a Germany splintered into 400 states, Luther's spark ignited the flame of rebellion against the empire and the privileges of the church.
I've just had an idea. Watch this.
What would you say to this wheel fitted with paddles and run by water?
Well, fine. Say no more. I see you're bored to tears.
Let's forget I said anything, I won't bring it up again.
But I've got another idea. Why don't we go down to the port and see if the children have returned?
Ah, that's a good idea.
In 1530, at the height of his power, Charles V was crowned emperor by Pope Clement VII.
But the Reformation was gaining ground. It had reached Geneva, where Calvin was continuing William Farrell's work.
The years go by, and still no sign of the youngsters.
1537, Jacques Cartier discovers and explores Canada.
The banner of France as the first waves over Mount Royal.
Wars, victories, and defeats multiply between Spain and France.
Don't tell me he didn't like the land of gold.
My native land! I'm home! I'm home!
In 1543, the Frenchman Ambroise Paré invented the ligation of arteries.
In Flanders, André Vassal dissected the human body.
And Copernicus finally published his treatise on the Earth's road fish.
Lord, sir, I've got marbles to show you.
I'm certain you'll be most interested.
No.
Wait, see, here. Potatoes?
Green beans?
Potatoes?
Chocolate?
Gold. Got any?
No, but I've got much more. Look at this marvel, it's a turkey.
Not interested.
Come now, come now, come now.
Tobacco.
Look!
One moment. My name is van der Hoot from Amsterdam. I'm a merchant. I'll take everything you've shown.
Here.
That's not enough.
I'll forward the rest.
In 1545, after a long delay, a council met at Trent.
Figure in all this.
Ah, peak man!
Now calm down, I've still got something you're sure to like.
Here.
Now then, why didn't you say so?
See, everything irons itself out.
Dutchman takes the rest.
There you go.
Both Francis I and Henry VIII died in 1547,
and Charles V beat the Protestant League
in the insignificant Battle of Milburg.
Children never come back.
In 1553, an exhausted Charles retires to Brussels.
But why should I only get half?
That ain't fair, I say.
Line up, line up.
Died of Augsburg, recognized the Protestant religion in late 1554.
Maybe it's our lucky day, who knows, the next boat might just bring our boys home.
Charles V abdicated the throne and Philip II took over.
Nothing yet, I can't take much more of this.
1558 saw the death of Charles V.
He claimed to have fought not for fame, but for the good of his states and subjects.
That same year, Elizabeth became Queen of England.
And in 1559, she made peace with France.
Philip II had won the war, but his country had suffered badly.
1571, Spain takes heart after her victory at Lepanto.
One young soldier lost a hand in battle, not his writing hand.
His name was Cervantes.
1588, the invincible armada, symbol of Spain's golden age, sailed for England.
What would survive Valdez' grandeur?
The impressive Escorial.
Lope de Vega's picture of the glories and contradictions of his era.
The pure faith of St. Teresa of Avila.
El Greco.
And the one-armed warrior, Cervantes, gave us the legendary Don Quixote.